[Musik]
tag 9 in putins krieg gegen die ukraine
schwerer beschuss auf das größte
atomkraftwerk europas präsident zellen
ski spricht von einem noch nie
dagewesenen des terrors auch der angriff
auf kiew geht weiter aber der widerstand
auch kiews bürgermeister vitali
klitschko gibt sich kämpferisch
einfach aufgeben
und wer
guten abend willkommen zum zdf spezial
angesichts der russischen übermacht hat
die ukraine deutschland dringend um die
lieferung schwerer waffen gebeten panzer
hubschrauber u boote die wunschliste ist
lang entschieden ist darüber noch nicht
heikel ist es auf jeden fall denn die
sorge vor einem großen krieg in europa
die wächst an vielen stellen in der
ukraine sind die kampfhandlungen
fortgesetzt worden auch der beschuss von
wohngebieten in städten martin hanika
fast den tag zusammen
der tag beginnt mit einer drohenden
katastrophe
das atomkraftwerk sapori cia steht unter
russischem beschuss der ukrainische
präsident spricht von terror
wir haben eine nacht durchgestanden die
das ende der geschichte hätte sein
können der geschichte der ukraine der
geschichte europas russische truppen
haben das größte atomkraftwerk in europa
angegriffen es hätte sechs mal schlimmer
enden können als tschernobyl
es geht um das atomkraftwerk sapori cia
im südosten der ukraine das akw liegt in
der stadt enna oder etwas mehr als 50
kilometer luftlinie entfernt von der
großstadt favorisiert erst später wird
klar getroffen wurde nur ein
schulungsgebäude auf dem gelände nicht
aber die reaktoren die feuerwehr kann
den brand schließlich löschen die
russische propaganda behauptet von
ukrainern aus dem schulungsgebäude
beschossen worden zu sein
in der vergangenen nacht hat das
nationalistische regime aus kiew
versucht eine monströse provokation
durchzuführen um zwei uhr nachts während
eine mobile patrouille auf dem gelände
des atomkraftwerks buschehr unterwegs
war haben ukrainische saboteure das
feuer eröffnet
am vormittag melden beide seiten
übereinstimmend die russen hätten das
atomkraftwerk nun unter kontrolle
auch in der region rund um schumi rund
140 kilometer westlich von kiew hat es
diese nacht wieder angriffe gegeben nach
ukrainischen polizeiangaben haben dort
mehrere luftschläge siedlungen getroffen
noch in der nacht einen rettungskräfte
in die betroffenen gebiete am morgen
danach werden die immensen schäden
sichtbar getroffen wurde unter anderem
eine schule
in der 285 1000 einwohner stadt terni
hilft nordöstlich von kiew hatte es
gestern schon russische luftangriffe auf
wohngebiete gegeben dabei sind wie
ukrainische behörden heute melden 47
menschen getötet worden gestern waren
sie noch von 33 getöteten ausgegangen
wegen schweren beschuss hatten die
rettungsdienste nach eigenen angaben
ihre arbeiten zeitweise aussetzen müssen
währenddessen sollen diese vom
russischen verteidigungsministerium
veröffentlichten bilder zeigen wie die
truppen bei vier vorrücken in den
letzten tagen war immer wieder von einem
riesigen russischen konvoi im nordwesten
von kiew berichtet worden der offenbar
in stocken geraten war
in münchen begrüße ich den ex bundeswehr
general erich fahrt guten abend genau
dieser vorlauf es werden heftige kämpfe
gemeldet auch in der nähe der hauptstadt
kiew wie schätzen sie aktuell den
russischen truppen vormarsch ein
ja die ukrainischen verteidiger kämpfen
sehr zäh an allen fronten
dennoch ist es den russen insbesondere
im süden gelungen land zu gewinnen die
verbindung also von der crème in den dom
bass die landverbindung haben sie
erreicht auch wenn sie sehr schmal ist
und westlich der krim marschieren sie
offensichtlich auf den raum odessa zu im
norden sieht es anders aus charkow in
den großstädten insgesamt laufen kämpfe
kiew wird gerade eingekesselt um es
zitat auszutrocknen das ist die
russische strategie man will prioritär
nicht in die städte reihen man versucht
an ihnen vorbei sie einzuschließen und
daneben punktuell in die stadt rein zu
gehen und dort militärisch wichtige
infrastruktur polizei geheimdienst usw
zu neutralisieren das wird bei kiew
nicht so sein können denn da müssen sie
schon mit massiven kräften rein und es
ist ein verlustreicher straßen und
häuser kampf zu erwarten so wie das
jetzt aussieht das klingt mich gut der
ukrainische botschafter in deutschland
hat die liste der benötigten
waffenlieferungen erweitert wünscht sich
auch panzer und u-boote sollte die
bundesregierung diese wünsche erfüllen
ja ich denke die bundesregierung hatte
entschieden bei den waffen die formen
behutsam zu bleiben also eher einen
defensiven bereich die forderungen der
ukraine sind natürlich verständlich man
muss aber sehen dass bei diesem
großgerät das nicht so einfach ist die
kann man nicht dahin schicken sondern
die müssen dahin transportiert werden da
muss technik mit da muss ausbildung
betrieben werden da muss die munition
verbracht werden das ist ganz anders als
bei den panzerabwehrwaffen oder bei den
boden luft raketen raketen die auch für
die momentane gefechtssituation der
ukraine besser zu gebrauchen sind und
eigentlich einen höheren gefechts wert
haben als jetzt wochen lang auf
großgerät zu warten dazu kommt dass die
bundeswehr ja selber kaum u boote hat
und mit ihrem großgerät sieht es auch
nicht ganz besonders gut aus kann man
den abschätzen ab wann waffenlieferungen
an die ukraine von der russischen seite
als provokation gewertet werden
das ist immer eine sehr sensitive frage
da muss man sehr behutsam sein wichtig
ist dass man auch die waffenlieferungen
politisch steuert denn waffenlieferungen
sind ja schon ein schritt in richtung
stellvertreterkrieg und man ist im
grunde genommen auf dem weg
konfliktpartei zu werden aber das will
man politisch nicht was will die nato
nicht das will auch die deutsche
bundesregierung nicht insofern ist da
eine gezielte politische steuerung sehr
wichtig die nato wird ja den wunsch der
ukraine eine flugverbotszone
einzurichten nicht nachkommen können sie
nochmal kurz erklären warum das keine
option ist
ja wir kennen ja flugverbotszonen aus
anderen szenarien wir haben das anfang
der 90er jahre zum beispiel im irak
gemacht um die kurden zu schützen sie
sind auch etabliert worden auf dem
balkan in libyen in der regel von einer
militärisch überlegenen macht gegenüber
einem
kontrahenten der über luftwaffe verfügt
aber nur rudimentär das ist hier
natürlich anders man muss hier einfach
sagen wenn man eine flugverbotszone für
russische flugzeuge
etabliert muss die überwacht werden das
heißt auch deutsche eurofighter werden
sich daran beteiligen müssen
das heißt im klartext wenn russische
flugzeuge da rein fliegen müssen sie
abgeschossen werden und das bedeutet
faktisch
einen ziemlich sicheren schritt in einen
krieg vielen dank für das gespräch erich
fahrt vielen dank herr vorlauf
kriege bringen zerstörung und leid bei
diesem krieg ist das ausmaß noch gar
nicht absehbar doch die gefahren die von
ihm ausgehen sind groß in der nacht
wurde nach heftigen gefechten ein feuer
an europas grösstem atomkraftwerks
apolonia im süden der ukraine gemeldet
der brand wurde gelöscht die
reaktorblöcke blieben verschont doch die
sorge bleibt auch weil der vorfall
erinnerungen weckt an die
atomkatastrophe von tschernobyl
russische panzer vor der atom ruine von
tschernobyl bilder die die einnahme der
sperrzone letzte woche zeigen sollen es
ist der ort an dem es vor 36 jahren zum
super gau kam tausende menschen starben
durch die verstrahlung eine radioaktive
wolke breitet sich über die gesamte
nordhalbkugel aus
in tschernobyl sind die verbliebenen
reaktorblöcke längst abgeschaltet nicht
aber im rest des landes
an vier standorten gibt es insgesamt 15
aktive reaktoren mehr als die hälfte des
ukrainischen stroms kommt noch immer aus
der kernenergie
das jetzt von russischen streitkräften
eingenommen kraftwerk sa borussia ist
das größte in europa sechs
druckwasserreaktoren gibt es hier ein
anderer typ als in tschernobyl aber wie
alle im land stammen sie aus
sowjetischer zeit die technik gilt als
robust ist aber über 30 jahre alt immer
wieder kommt es zu störfällen und um
direkten beschuss auszuhalten ist das
kraftwerk nicht ausgelegt bei denen
kämpfen letzte nacht schlugen die chance
ein ein gebäude auf dem gelände brannte
wir hatten natürlich glück dass keine
strahlung ausgetreten ist und dass die
reaktoren selbst nicht beschädigt wurden
fünf der reaktoren sind offenbar
inzwischen aus gefahr besteht aber nicht
nur durch beschuss sondern auch dann
wenn der strom dauerhaft ausfällt denn
die brennstäbe müssen gekühlt werden
auch nach der abschaltung
diesel-generatoren könnten dass einige
tage lang übernehmen so lange genug
treibstoff da ist in köln begrüße ich
jetzt den reaktor sicherheitsexperten
professor manfred mertins guten abend
gute vorne an europas grösstem
atomkraftwerk hat es nach beschuss
gebrannt wie gefährlich ist so eine
situation
also die anlagen kernkraftwerke neuerer
bauart muss man sagen sind dagegen im
grunde ausgelegt gegen brände die in der
umgebung des kraftwerkes auftreten
können und
welche stelle eines atommeilers ist
durch einen angriff besonders gefährdet
also der zentrale aspekt der sicherheit
ist die kühlung der anlage ganz
gefährlich ist wenn die kühlung ausfällt
dann
gehen wir im ganz gefährliche szenarien
im kraftwerk und es ist in jedem fall
sicherzustellen dass die kühlung nicht
beendet werden kann nicht still gelegt
werden kann und hier haben eine
gefährliche stellungen kraftwerk ist das
ein moderner reaktor über den wir hier
sprechen in der ukraine
wird die anlage über die wir hier reden
das sind die anlagen im akw abrashi das
sind sechs blöcke der sogenannten b wert
1000 generation das sind relativ neue
anlagen diese sicherheitstechnisch
vergleichbar durchaus mit einer ganzen
reihe von westeuropäischen anlagen sind
nicht das neueste das muss man sagen und
dafür nicht mehr die normandy heute an
die sicherheit gestellt werden denken
wir mal an den worst case was wären denn
die auswirkungen einer kernschmelze im
reaktor
es ist natürlich eine kernschmelze im
reaktor ist an sich eine
unvorstellbare geschichte muss ich sagen
gerade in der gegend über die wir hier
reden das ist ja alles sehr eng
bevölkert aber wenn ich europa im blick
habe das ist natürlich die freisetzung
die da auftreten im bereich der ukraine
ist gefährlich für für große bereiche
der ukraine abhängig jetzt von der
windrichtung
gibt es natürlich dann auch und wären
auswirkungen auf europa auf
zentraleuropa hier bei uns möglich also
ich mag nicht daran denken wir
überschreiten hier eine rote linie muss
ich sagen was die gefährdung der anlagen
der kriegerischen einwirkung angeht das
ist
für mich nicht vorstellbar und hier
darf es eigentlich so was ich wem ich
hätte das nie aber ab dass wir über so
was reden müssen
hilft es denn in dieser situation die
atommeiler abzuschalten vom netz zu
nehmen
ja diese vorstellung könnte man haben
muss man sagen aber bei den
atomreaktoren es ist ja so dass der
brennstoff wenn wir ihn abschalten
noch eine nachzerfallswärme entwickelt
die bei diesen anlagen schon beachtliche
größen werte größen erreicht also wir
haben so etwa mit sechs prozent der
leistung müssen wir rechnen die als
restwärme dennoch auftritt das sind dort
etwa so 180 megawatt
die müssen wirklich durch die
kühlsysteme weggefahren werden das heißt
also abschalten ist natürlich in jedem
fall richtig und nötig aber damit ist
sie sich hat noch längst nicht
gewährleistet dann fängt das er im
grunde erst einmal hier die wärme durch
notkühlsysteme wechsel transportieren
also es abschalten allein ist nicht
ausreichend
die sicherheit wird dann erst
beeinträchtigt herr professor martins
vielen dank für diese information
das gespräch haben wir aufgezeichnet die
kampfbereitschaft der ukraine ist hoch
so hoch dass sie viele auch experten
überrascht
auch unerfahrene ziehen entschlossen in
den krieg zivilisten stellen sich vor
rollende panzer bilder davon gibt es
unzählige in den sozialen medien
ob sie echt sind lässt sich nicht immer
überprüfen doch fest steht dieser krieg
ist auch zum kampf um bilder auf
instagram und twitter geworden auffällig
dabei ist die rolle des ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky der verstanden hat
wie er mit seinem volk und der welt
kommunizieren muss und das hält die
moral hoch
olivgrünes t shirt der blick ernst
direkt in die kamera so wendet sich der
ukrainische präsident seit tagen immer
wieder an seine landsleute und die ganze
welt wolodimir selensky nutzt alle
kanäle um auf den krieg das leid in
seinem land aufmerksam den ukrainern mut
zu machen die botschaft ich bin einer
von euch die ukraine sollen bleiben der
westen soll heißen
ich werde in der hauptstadt bleiben
meine familie ist auch in der ukraine
genau wie meine kinder
wir sind keine verräter wir sind bürger
der ukraine
den genauen ort wo sie sich befinden
werde ich nicht nennen denn nach den
informationen die wir haben bin ich das
ziel nummer eins und meine familie das
ziel nummer zwei des feindes
sie wollen der ukraine politisch schaden
indem so das staatsoberhaupt umbringen
der präsident wird innerhalb kürzester
zeit zur symbolfigur des widerstands
gegen die invasion er führt die ukraine
durch ihre wohl schwerste zeit nutzt die
macht der bilder der sozialen medien die
strategie geht auf er mobilisiert
motiviert auch welche lenski und sein
team nahezu im stundentakt videos posten
zielinski omnipräsent als präsident
vater kamerad
das verschafft ihm weltweit respekt
ihre der ukraine
die anzahl der twitter follower von
selensky hat sich verzehnfacht seit
kriegsbeginn
und es sind vor allem menschen aus dem
internationalen bereich dazugekommen aus
anderen ländern das heißt selensky
erreicht jetzt eine globale
öffentlichkeit und er kann druck ausüben
vor allem auf die westlichen länder
damit die unterstützung für die ukraine
noch gesteigert wird zielinski will
beistand und mittel denn er steht vor
seiner größten herausforderung er muss
sein volk zusammenhalten ein präsident
manövriert die ukraine durch den krieg
nach gerade einmal zwei jahren im amt in
denen er von beginn an senkt image als
versöhner des volkes pflegt
liebe ukraine auch meine wahlsieg hat
man sechs jahre alter sohn zu mir gesagt
heißt das
mag wie der witz eines kindes klingen
aber so aber mit der zeit habe ich
verstanden das stimmt
jeder einzelne von rose ist
präsident 2009 10 gewählt wird weiß er
sich zu inszenieren ist politisch jedoch
völlig unerfahren viele trauen ihm das
amt des präsidenten nicht zu das gesicht
des ehemaligen schauspielers ist den
ukrainern im ganzen land bekannt durch
seine rolle als geschichtslehrer der
plötzlich präsident wird damals hat das
erfolgsformat diener des volkes viele
zum lachen gebracht rückblickend machen
viele szenen sprachlos seine rolle jetzt
der optimist das könnte putin
unterschätzt haben zwischen putin und
selensky ist der größtmögliche kontrast
im erscheinungsbild entstanden putin
sitzt alleine und grimmig in seinem
palast und selensky ist der tapfere
freiheitskämpfer auf der straße mit
seinen kameraden zielinski richtet sich
auch immer wieder an die russische
bevölkerung auch auf emotionaler ebene
auch auf russisch und er wehrt sich
gegen falschinformationen selensky der
jüdische wurzeln hat reagiert so nachdem
putin ihn als nazi beschimpft hat
wie kann ich ein nazi sein erklären sie
das mal in meinem großvater dem
weltkrieg in der infanterie der
sowjetischen armee mit gekämpft hat und
als oberst in einer unabhängigen ukraine
gestorben ist den frieden in der ost
ukraine hat sie längst nicht erreicht
den krieg im ganzen land konnte er nicht
verhindern trotzdem ist er nun für viele
der starke der sich vor seine bürger und
gleichzeitig mit ihnen auf eine stufe
stellt in diesem krieg ein wichtiges
signal
und wir beschäftigen uns jetzt mit dem
russischen präsidenten und dazu begrüßt
sich in berlin die journalistin und
autorin katja gloger die eine biografie
über wladimir putin geschrieben hat und
sich intensiv mit seiner gedankenwelt
befasst hat guten abend
helfen sie uns doch zu verstehen was
putin mit diesem angriffskrieg bezweckt
und warum er ihn offenbar für völlig
legitim hält
in diesen tagen erinnern wir uns ja oft
das wort von angela merkel vor ein paar
jahren dass putin in einer anderen welt
lebe das scheint wirklich so zu sein
eine realität die er uns allen nun auch
zwingend erbarmungslos und das coupé los
und mit seinem angriffskrieg mit dem
erklärten ziel die ukraine und zu
unterwerfen verfolgt er glaube ich zwei
große ziele das eine ist ein kühles
geostrategisches ziel mit der
unterwerfung der ukraine und belarus
dass er ja faktisch kontrolliert
die hegemonie in der region herzustellen
ein puffer gebiet zum westen
herzustellen und damit dann auch am ende
ein vetorecht über die politik über die
außenpolitik die politik osteuropäische
und damit westlicher staaten zu haben
dem zugrunde aber liegt ein weltsicht
die sich als gegensatz zum westen
definiert eine konfrontative eine
misstrauische welt sich die in
verschwörungs notenwart
putin hat das erklärte ziel auf einer
heiligen historischen mission zu sein um
das alte russland das große imperium mit
seinem ganz eigenen werten die ganz
anders sind als die das vermeintlich so
dekadenten westen wieder herzustellen
gibt es den vorgänger aus ihrer sicht
bewege putin zu erreichen und den krieg
zu stoppen
das gleicht fast eine quadratur des
kreises in diesen tagen weil all das was
uns herein nicht um uns erreicht ja
nicht viel sagen aus dem kreml von gegen
ganz langen tischen an denen wladimir
putin vor ein paar tagen saß dass er
fest entschlossen ist um nahezu jeden
preis den sieg den militärischen sieg in
der ukraine zu erringen um so wichtiger
ist es natürlich das
diplomatische kanäle gesprächskanäle
aufrechterhalten werden der französische
präsident marco macht des bund der
bundeskanzler hat es heute getan so
klein die hoffnung auch sein mag ihn
dazu zu bewegen
wenigstens auf ernsthafte gespräche zu
einem waffenstillstand einzugehen putin
ist ja de facto über 20 jahre schon an
der macht sehen sie anzeichen dafür dass
er mit diesem krieg seine eigene
position gefährdet
er antwortet in seinem eigenen land mit
immer zu nur mit den massiven
repressionen das jüngste mediengesetz
ist ein beispiel dafür all die
verhaftungen mehr auch friedlicher
demonstranten er hat eine nationalgarde
seit jahren schon die allein ihm
unterstellt ist mehrere hunderttausend
man groß also dass es seine dass dieser
krieg seine direkte macht nun gefährdet
das scheint im moment wenig möglich man
kann
hoffen vielleicht auf eine art
palastrevolte all derer die bislang so
sehr von ihm profitiert haben und die
jetzt in ihren geldflüssen auf null
gestellt sind was wird denn putin tun
wenn es schlecht läuft für ihn in diesem
krieg und er sich in die enge gedrängt
fühlt ist der einsatz von atomwaffen in
seiner logik auch legitim
die russische
sicherheitsstrategie soweit jedes
nachvollziehen können sieht durchaus
auch den einsatz taktischer atomwaffen
vor
um so zurückhaltend der angesichts
dieses risikos und angesichts der
bereitschaft blutiges ja weit zu gehen
umso zurückhaltender ist bislang die
reaktion des westens vor allen dingen
der vereinigten staaten die nun
versuchen auch rhetorisch vielleicht ein
wenig abzurüsten die ja erklären dass
die harten sanktionen die der westen
verhängt hat und die sehr schnell ja
auch auswirkungen auf die russische
wirtschaft zeigen dass diese harten
sanktion nicht dazu da sind das lernen
zu bestrafen sondern dazu da sind
punkten allein verhandlungstisch zu
bringen um mögliche wege sagen aus
diesen krieg hinaus zu finden
rhetorische die eskalation ist dabei
wichtig vielen dank katja gloger für das
gespräch nach berlin
dank
der morgen begann mit der
schreckensmeldung über den brand an
einem atomkraftwerk der russische
aufmarsch und einmarsch geht weiter
ebenso bombardierungen raketenbeschuss
kämpfe auch heute ist noch kein
waffenstillstand in sicht geschweige
denn ein ende des krieges aber
gleichzeitig organisiert organisiert
sich auch im ganzen land der widerstand
und machen die freiwilligen mobil
berichtet gert anhalt
wir zwischen zwei flieger alarmen seine
arznei abholen will der muss sich auf
langes warten einstellen die zweite
kriegswoche bringt neue angst nach kiew
und immer unsicherer wird auch die
versorgungslage in der bedrängten
hauptstadt nur noch wenige geschäfte
haben geöffnet und das sortiment wird
mit jedem tag kleiner
es gibt kein fleisch mehr wie sie sehen
alles ist leer und einer fehlen und auch
frische milch es gibt überhaupt keine
frischen produkte mehr
entbehrungen und die ungewissheit zehren
an den nerven und mehr noch der
bedrohliche kanonendonner der tag und
nacht aus dem umland grollt die logistik
sei zusammengebrochen erklärt
bürgermeister klitschko im zdf noch aber
funktioniere die kritische infrastruktur
elektrisierten stadt ist noch da
die wir jetzt strom und will sagt
schalten
ist heizung ist
trinkwasser
regale sind zwar vielerorts leergeräumt
doch hauptsache es kommt noch genug
material für die heimwehr zusammen sagen
diese frauen zahnbürsten kekse warme
kleidung sie stellen pakete für die
bürger milizen zusammen die draußen in
der kälte die straßen sperren und panzer
fallen bemannen der baron unsere
verteidiger sind absolut vorbereitet für
ihren einsatz
auch wenn dies vielleicht kein kriegs
entscheidender beitrag ist sie sind froh
dass sie helfen können und nicht
tatenlos daheim sitzen während das
schicksal ihres landes auf dem spiel
steht
panzer igel nennen sie die hastig
zusammengeschweißten krallen mit denen
sie die zufahrtsstraßen blockieren das
sind mehr als nur sehr effektive panzer
stopper diese konstrukte gelten vor
allem in osteuropa auch als symbole für
widerstand um jeden preis
wir die russen zurückschlagen können
weiß ich nicht bin ja kein general wir
werden es jedenfalls versuchen
fragen sie unseren präsidenten
lehrer kraftfahrer
verwaltungsangestellte lernen unter
anleitung von sanitätern die
erstversorgung von schuss und schrapnell
wunden anwälte und handwerker fällen
bäume so wie es der
verteidigungsminister empfohlen hat
alles aber auch alles soll genutzt
werden um die angreifer aufzuhalten
und wenn es nötig wird sind sie bereit
ihre heimatstadt aus dem schützengraben
heraus zu verteidigen
ich glaube dass wir gewinnen werden aber
leicht wird es nicht aber wir werden sie
zerbrechen und zwar so dass sich ihre
kinder und enkel noch daran erinnern
viele befürchten dass selbst der
berühmte meydan platz im zentrum zum
schlachtfeld werden könnte ihm
vielleicht bald bevorstehenden sturm auf
kiew auf den werbeflächen werden die
russischen soldaten bereits mit derben
verwünschungen bedacht
auch dort wo noch kein russischer panzer
gesichtet wurde wie im städtchen bila
zerkwa 80 kilometer südlich ist der
frieden weit weg und gelten alle
gedanken und mühen der abwehr russischer
angreifer hier haben sich bereits
hunderte menschen beim heimatschutz
gemeldet und sind mit der produktion von
brandbomben befasst die an die
kontrollpunkte geliefert werden bis zu
1500 leere wodkaflaschen füllen sie
täglich
mit denen sich die im straßenkampf noch
unerprobten freiwilligen erst einmal
vertraut machen müssen
sie wenn vier stück hintereinander das
ziel treffen aber manche explodieren
auch gar nicht jedenfalls sollte man
darauf achten immer vier auf einen
panzer zu werfen um ihre reichweite zu
erhöhen schweißen sie in der traktoren
werkstatt ein katapult zusammen bis zu
50 meter weit könnten sie damit
austeilen wir haben zwar nicht viel
sagen sie aber sie wollen alles in die
schlacht werfen und die kämpfer so gut
es geht versorgen und aufbauen
wir sammeln jetzt nicht nur medikamente
sondern auch energie drinks und protein
cocktails sie die im sport verwendet
werden es ist total stressig an den
checkpoints wo unsere jungs stundenlang
in der kälte stehen
selbst in lemberg tief im westen und
unweit der polnischen grenze lässt die
angst vor den russen die bürger zu den
schaufeln greifen um im stadtpark einen
alten luftschutzraum freizulegen hier
sollen im notfall 100 menschen schutz
vor bomben und raketen finden
ich habe sowas auch noch nie gemacht ich
bin von beruf innenarchitekt aber jetzt
bin ich freiwilliger helfer und bis der
krieg vorbei ist mache ich das hier und
dann müssen wir unser land wieder
aufbauen
dass sie auch fernab der jetzigen
angriffs linien in gefahr sind ahnten
die lemberger spätestens als auf ihren
hausdächern und an strategischen punkten
die sonderbaren markierungen aus fonds
vorlag auftauchten damit könnte der
feind sich orientieren oder die stadt
bombardieren wer eine markierung findet
soll sie sofort vernichten ordneten die
behörden an und mahnte zur wachsamkeit
russische agenten sind längst überall im
einsatz
im westen der ukraine bin ich jetzt
verbunden mit unserer reporterin katrin
eigendorf hallo kathrin
hallo am atomkraftwerk in sapporo cia
gab es nach russischen beschuss ein
brand das haben ja gesehen der sendung
vorhin ist das eine nachricht die die
menschen bei ihnen erreicht hat und was
löst sie aus
ja diese nachricht hat die menschen hier
erreicht dass der reaktor separee ist
von hier ja nur 600 kilometer entfernt
und hier in der stadt wurde heute über
megaphone im prinzip geschildert wie die
lage ist immer wieder aufgerufen dazu
sich gedanken darüber zu machen dass
möglicherweise auch andere
kernkraftwerke hier unter beschuss
kommen können das wurde verurteilt von
der stadtverwaltung hier aber
erstaunlicherweise waren die meisten
menschen mit denen wir hier geredet
haben relativ besonnen also von panik
war hier überhaupt nichts zu spüren
obwohl
ein weiteres ukrainisches kernkraftwerk
940 kilometer von hier entfernt ist wenn
man sich das gesamtbild anguckt dann
schätze ich war dieser schlag putins vor
allem auf europa gerichtet denn putin
merkt er dass die sympathie und der
rückhalt mit der ukrainischen
bevölkerung wahnsinnig groß ist dass die
sanktionen gegen ihn immer härter werden
und im prinzip wollte er will er glaube
ich das ist seine strategie damit angst
und schrecken erzeugen also eine umkehr
im prinzip von sympathie zu angst um das
eigene leben denn bis jetzt geht es um
das leben der ukraine aber sollte hier
wirklich ein kernkraftwerk in die luft
gehen oder sogar tschernobyl
angegriffen werden das ja auch unter
kontrolle der russen ist dann wäre das
natürlich für die europäer eine
katastrophe was haben sie denn heute mit
ihrem team vor ort erlebt
wir waren heute mit unserem team
mehrfach in der stadt haben hier mit
leuten gesprochen was die er erlebt
haben es ist nicht so dass die leute
sich auf einmal zurückgezogen haben
sondern die stadt ist damit beschäftigt
lebensmittel zu bringen um die
flüchtlinge zu versorgen viele
flüchtlinge sind ja hier aus dem osten
der ukraine
angekommen es gibt auch sehr viele aus
kiew die hier in hotels bei verwandten
und irgendwo in den kommunalen
einrichtungen untergebracht sind also
viele leute kümmern sich um deren
versorgung man knüpft hier auch netze
für die front stellt sachen zusammen um
die zu den soldaten zu bringen also im
prinzip bereitet man und bereitet man
sich hier auf den krieg vor und
unterstützt auch ganz klar dass
den widerstand der ukraine insgesamt
vielen dank für diese eindrücke katrin
eigendorf
seit einigen tagen bitten wir menschen
in der ukraine uns zu schildern was sie
erleben wie es ihnen geht wir sprechen
mit ihnen über skype sie schicken uns
handyvideos das nimmt dem krieg das
abstrakte es lässt uns anteil nehmen an
gedanken gefühlen ängsten und wünschen
derer die im krieg mit dem krieg leben
hier sind einige stimmen die banken
kriegen direkt in die wohnhäuser also
von den rosen kann man jetzt von
offiziellen also politikern
inoffiziellen berichten kann man hören
lesen dass die drogen nur militärobjekte
beschießen das stimmt nicht die
beschießen zivilisten sie beschießen
wohnhäuser da gibt es in der nähe so gut
wie keine militärobjekte sie zielen
direkt auf die zivil
zivilbevölkerung und auch die ganz
normalen wohnhäusern ich persönlich
würde gar nicht glauben an die garantien
die angeblich gegeben
worden sind das heißt dass diese
korridore
sicher sein soll das glaube ich
persönlich nicht und ich würde möchte
braucht nicht verlassen weil sie
gewinnen komm lass uns ein interview
geben
hallo meine kleine
es ist deutlich sicherer hier und
stiller als intakt hier gibt es keinen
fliegeralarm keine bomben oder
explosionen und luftangriff
wir werden hier jetzt erst mal für ein
paar tage bleiben
gerade schlafen wir hier einfach auf dem
boden unsere sachen haben wir noch nicht
ausgepackt alles ist noch zusammen
gepackt
wir konnten noch spielsachen für unsere
tochter mitnehmen
ich muss nicht zur armee wegen meiner
gesundheit ich will auch eigentlich gar
keine waffe in den händen halten ich bin
pazifist
ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen wie
viele einladungen ich aus aller welt
bekommen um mich in sicherheit zu
bringen aber nein meine freunde bleiben
auch hier einige unserer politiker hauen
ab
[Musik]
wenn wir versuchen zu schlafen dann sind
unsere ohren draußen auf der straße wir
hören auf jedes geräusch
wenn ein kampf mit ja sehr niedrig
fliegt das geräusch ist gruselig
[Musik]
ich versuche videos aus aktiv erstmal
nicht anzuschauen
ich muss mich jetzt zusammenreißen ich
muss stark bleiben für mich und für
meine liebsten
ich bin aus kiew ich bin hier geboren
genau wie meine frau und meine kinder
wir sind echte kiel war am ersten tag um
fünf uhr früh wurden wir von
einschlagenden bomben geweckt ich habe
sie dann in unser sommerhaus außerhalb
geraten ich habe sie dort hingefahren
mit etwas essen
heute habe ich eine nachricht bekommen
dass sie nur noch essen für drei tage
haben ich kann aber nicht mehr zu nehmen
in zwei straßen dorthin sind von
russischen soldaten blockiert und deren
panzer
wir haben angst dass wir nicht mehr
zurück nach hat gekündigt oder dass wenn
wir zurückkehren nichts mehr von dem
archiv das wir kennen übrig ist
ich hoffe auf die regierung
ich hoffe auf meine mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger auf die ehrenamtliche
menschen und
immer ganz genau ganz konkret dass sie
einen sehr starken geist haben sie sind
stark motiviert ihr land zu verteidigen
und wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
helfen wollen können sie das tun beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine die bahn
de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf.de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
zugeschaltet ist jetzt unser moskau
korrespondent christian senn guten abend
schön
abend der kreml hat die bevölkerung
heute aufgerufen sich hinter putin zu
versammeln sich nicht spalten zu lassen
hat so ein appell aussicht auf erfolg
also ich würde sagen wenn man so einen
aufruf startet dann könnte man ja auch
zu dem gedanken kommen dass man an
diesem punkt einen defizit spürt das
könnte der hintergrund seien für diesen
aufruf das würde auch passend zu putins
rede gestern war ja noch mal betont hat
wie wichtig dieser einsatz ist und hat
noch mal geworben auch für den konflikt
mit der ukraine
also das könnte dazu passen ob dann
wirklich die massen dem folgen und wie
das konkret aussehen soll ob dann ob die
menschen dann wirklich für putin auf die
straße gehen soll das werden wir sehen
wer so genannte falsch nachrichten über
die russischen streitkräfte verbreitet
wird jetzt mit langen haftstrafen und
hohen geldbußen bedroht nur wer bestimmt
was einer falsch nachricht ist
ja das ist eine sehr gute frage dieses
neue gesetz das ist sehr schwammig
formuliert das kennen wir von anderen
restriktiven gesetzen so dass man zum
schluss gar nicht genau weiß in welchem
rahmen man sich bewegt aber es ist
richtig in dem gesetz steht wer falsche
nachrichten über die russische armee
verbreitet dem drohen bis zu 15 jahre
haft und das verunsichert natürlich hier
die journalistinnen und journalisten das
richtet sich vor allem an die russischen
kolleginnen und kollegen die er jetzt
aktuell auch wieder ganz massiv unter
druck sind wenn wir an den an den
radiosender echo moskwy denken oder an
tv dass der mittlerweile seinen
sendebetrieb eingestellt hat in dem
gesetz steht aber auch dass das auch für
ausländer gelten so ist auch unter den
internationalen korrespondenten die
verunsicherung groß was denn jetzt
eigentlich noch wirklich erlaubt ist und
die britische bbc die hat jetzt erste
schlüsse daraus gezogen und die wird
erst mal nicht mehr aus moskau berichten
bis vielleicht klarer ist was genau
damit gemeint ist ja auch das gehört zum
nebel des krieges vielen dank christian
siemers kam
der krieg geht auf strecke auch am
neunten tag sind die russischen
streitkräfte weit davon entfernt die
ziele zu erreichen die ihnen der kreml
vorgegeben hat die regierung seinen ski
ist nicht gestürzt die ukraine ist nicht
entwaffnet der widerstand von armee und
heimatschutz ist nicht gebrochen wieder
mussten zahlreiche soldaten und
zivilisten sterben am wochenende soll es
eine neue verhandlungsrunde geben
zwischen der ukraine und russland
allzu große hoffnungen kann man wohl
nicht daran knüpfen
aktuelle informationen finden sie
jederzeit bei zdf heute.de jetzt gleich
bei heute live und ab 21 uhr 45 im heute
journal
danke für ihr interesse auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
maybrit illner spezial mit dem thema
krieg in der ukraine mit dabei csu-chef
markus söder die deutschen kleineren
marina weisband und zdf journalist claus
kleber maybrit illner spezial